thanks to all of you for coming this
morning I can see so many faces here
it's fantastic to be back at Leeds
University where I spent three happy
years and thank you to the commission
members who've joined us this morning as
well
and thank you Tracy you're doing an
incredible job here in West Yorkshire
protecting the safety of women and girls
cheaper and better buses making this
region a hub of green industry
but I know that you could do so much
more I know the businesses here people
here communities here could do so much
more
but you're being held back
held back by A system that holds power
in Westminster
a system which smugly things
it knows what skills transport planning
a job support West Yorkshire needs
better than the people who live here
I've long been convinced that this
broken model has held back our politics
and held back our economy and I'm
determined we unbind ourselves
and free our potential
Britain is one of the most centralized
systems in Europe and the center has not
delivered
now I don't want it to fall apart I want
us to build something new
anyone can see what's happening in the
UK today
we have an unbalanced economy
one which makes too little use of the
talents of too few people in too few
places
and which the Tories have dragged into a
vicious cycle of low growth and high
taxes
faced with this narrow path of
stagnation
is it any surprise that people up and
down the country are crying out for a
new approach
now during the brexit referendum I
argued for remain
but I couldn't disagree with the basic
case that lots of lead voters made to me
they wanted more control over their
lives more control over their country
they wanted to create opportunities for
the Next Generation build communities
they felt proud of have public services
they could rely on
and I know that in the Scottish
referendum in 2014
many of those who voted yes
did so for similar reasons the same
frustrations at a Westminster system
that seems remote
the same yearning for the chance to
build a fairer future for themselves and
their families
people know Britain needs change
but they're never going to get it from
the Tories who talk about leveling up
but refuse to move power away from
Westminster
who once promised a stronger Union but
can't work with or for Scotland
and who think that the only route to
Prosperity is to make the rich richer
and hope that somehow it trickles down
to everyone else
to build the future our country deserves
means change
it means higher standards in public life
a wider spread of power and opportunity
and better economic growth that benefits
everyone wherever they are no more Naval
gazing or facing inwards
higher wider better
that is how Britain must set its size
and I'm determined that with labor
that's exactly what we will do
that's why I asked Gordon and the
commission to carry out a report of the
future of the UK
I asked them to put together proposal
for the biggest ever transfer of power
from Westminster to the British people
so that if labor wins the next election
Britain will see a change not just in
who governs
but how we are governed
the tools to a fairer society and a
stronger economy placed directly in the
hands of working people
so together we can build an economy not
just for the many
but by the many and of the many
now redistribution is a good thing
but it's not a one-word plan for a fair
Society or a strong economy
by empowering our towns cities regions
and Nations to work together on local
growth plans labor will reignite our
economy
new powers over skills transport
planning and culture all helping to
drive growth by developing hundreds of
clusters of economic activity
labor will rebuild Trust by reforming
the center of government
cleaning up slaves nourishing the
relationship between central government
and the devolved authorities
and replacing the unelected House of
Lords with a new smaller democratically
elected second chamber
not only less expensive
but also representing the regions and
nations of the United Kingdom
and labor will reunite our country with
New Missions based on our shared values
and priorities cooperating to tackle
climate change and addressing inequality
giving Scotland Wales Northern Ireland
and the regions of England new status
and louder prouder voices in a reformed
and modern United Kingdom
I want to thank Gordon and the
commission for their work
they've put forward a compelling vision
of how we can break Britain's economic
and political malaise how we can restore
trust to British politics
how we can offer a fairer Greener future
to the whole of our United Kingdom
that vision is underpinned by serious
and bold recommendations
and these will now be a matter of public
consultation
so they can be tested refined and made
ready for implementation
we will set out our final plans in our
Manifesto
and I invite everyone who wants to build
that fair or Greener future to get
involved
whether you voted leave or remain
yes or no
live in a city or town we will make
common cause with you
together we will Forge something bold
something modern something hopeful
together we will build a better future
thank you
[Applause]